the movie is set in the year 1962 when
the united states and the soviet union
are at each other's neck in america
there is a rumor that the soviets may
drop a nuclear bomb any time prompting
many citizens to build a secret bunker
in their house eccentric scientist dr
calvin weber is one of those citizens
and after months of hard work he has
built an advanced fallout bunker in his
backyard which has all the amenities
required to survive a nuclear war one
day calvin organizes a party at his
house and invites several of his
colleagues while everyone is enjoying
themselves president kennedy announces
on live television that they are
planning a secret mission against the
soviets this terrifies calvin and he
believes that the war is about to
commence shortly hence he sends all the
guests away and hurries to the secret
bunker alongside his pregnant wife helen
at the same time an aircraft is flying
over the city when it experiences a
mechanical failure it crashes straight
into calvin's house destroying it
completely inside the bunker calvin
deduces that the nuclear war has begun
and immediately seals the door he then
tells his wife that the door will open
only after 35 years as it takes the same
time for nuclear particles to normalize
in the atmosphere with the house
completely destroyed the weber's
neighbors and authorities assumed they
were killed in the crash now with each
passing day the couple starts adjusting
to life inside the bunker while calvin
feels at home helen is uncomfortable and
constantly worries about her family and
friends one day helen's water breaks and
she gives birth to a son the couple is
over the moon to have a child and they
name him adam in the following scene we
see a bigger view of their bunker it is
stocked to last for 35 years including a
fish tank fuels a well-facilitated
lounge area and a mini-mart full of food
as time passes calvin homeschools his
son and teaches him about the history of
america he wishes his son could one day
rebuild the country as it was before the
movie then skips to the summer of 1965
when a team of construction workers
cleans out calvin's destroyed ground and
builds a diner cut to 10 more years it
is now the autumn of 1975. adam has
grown into a kind and generous boy who
likes spending time with his parents he
takes regular boxing classes from his
father and dance classes from his mother
meanwhile the diner becomes a pizzeria
and then a nightclub in the basement
calvin continues to teach his son about
various topics he explains about the
stock market and gives lessons in french
and latin while they talk calvin
compliments his son's incredible sense
of humor one day calvin gives adam a
collection of his baseball cards and
explains to him about sports the movie
then skips to the summer of 1995 where
calvin and helen celebrate their son's
33rd birthday adam is a grown man now
who desires to find a partner for
himself next it's 1997 and the bunker
has reached its maturity finally after
35 years the bunker's door automatically
unlocks itself and the family excitedly
goes to check calvin insists that they
wait for the night and let him check
first since they don't know about the
present world outside above the bunker
the diner has now become a home to
beggars while the beggars are drinking
there's a sudden shaking of the ground
and they think it's an earthquake
however it turns out that calvin has
come up to the surface with a radiation
suit on and seeing him one of the
beggars falls unconscious following this
calvin ventures out into his old
neighborhood only to find out that it is
completely changed he sees people
playfully pointing guns at him and even
stumbles into an adult video store
realizing that his neighborhood has
degraded he becomes worried and returns
to the bunker at the dinner table he
shares with his family that although the
ground above is breathable it has become
a post-apocalyptic wasteland of
irradiated mutants as a result they must
continue living underground helen who at
this point has become sick of living in
the bunker starts arguing she mentions
that no matter the people above she
wants to come out of their cooped shell
and wants adam to see the blue skies
touch the oceans and grass and visit the
mountains despite the inspiring speech
calvin still insists that they stay
underground but as he is arguing he
suffers a heart attack with supplies
running out and calvin falling ill helen
wants adam to go outside and get
whatever they need for two years or so
she gives him a list of grocery items
and tells him that it would be wonderful
if he can find a girl one who's not a
mutant before leaving calvin advises
adam to not enter the adult video store
claiming that it has harmful levels of
radiation actually he is just trying to
keep his son away from vulgarity 35
years old is too young to experience
your first boner son after a while adam
packs his handbag and leaves the bunker
for the first time on the surface he
comes across the beggar melker who
encountered his father the previous
knight while adam marvels at the outside
world melker starts worshiping calvin
and the elevator through which he and
adam made their way out malker thinks of
them as some divine power that has
struck his life to change his fate
melker's been drinking too much
listerine meanwhile adam finally sees
the blue sky above and waves at people
in the streets as he is seeing them for
the first time he stunned to see a woman
of color and greets her excitedly next
he stumbles upon the same adult video
store his father had warned him about so
he quickly covers his nose and urges
others to do the same later adam gets on
a bus but he is scared to feel the
vehicle moving he speaks as per his
taught knowledge but that apparently
doesn't fit with the normal life at
present the passengers on the bus think
that he is crazy and the bus driver even
gives him a weird stare after a while
adam finally arrives at a grocery store
and strolls around to pick up the items
his mom had listed for him when he goes
to buy meat the butcher tells him that
if he makes a larger order it would be
directly delivered to his house hearing
the word house adam realizes that he has
forgotten the way back to his bunker
worried he desperately looks around the
city for his bunker's location but
doesn't find any sign of it by this
point his cash has almost run out so he
tries to sell his father's classic
baseball cards at a hobby shop the shop
owner concludes that adam is crazy for
trying to sell the cards for a
surprisingly low price so he offers to
buy the whole pack for just 500
just then the shop's assistant eve
approaches the two and stops the owner
from cheating she informs adam that each
of his cards costs at least six thousand
dollars as they are all extremely rare
she then berates her boss and quits her
job on the spot witnessing all this adam
is instantly smitten with her after
coming out of the store he begs eve to
drive him to the holiday inn restaurant
as per his mother's instructions at
first he refuses but when adam promises
to give her two cards in return she
agrees soon the two arrive at the hotel
but before adam can say anything eve
returns home the following morning adam
gets a call from eve who asks him to
come down to the lounge area it turns
out that she has come to give back his
card since she feels guilty after
returning the card she tries to walk
away but adam asks her to help purchase
supplies in exchange for a thousand
dollars a week as her pay eve agrees and
they buy truckloads of supplies as adam
has to make sure that the supplies last
for at least two years later he also
asks if to help him find a wife one who
is not a mutant in the next scene adam
meets eve's gay housemate and best
friend troy who is a bit curious by
nature he asks adam about his hometown
and the latter lies that he is
originally from alaska and has come here
for a business trip later even troy gave
adam a fashion makeover and the two even
take him skateboarding imagine the 90s
feeling like the future next adam gets
the chance to see the ocean for the
first time and he excitedly dives into
the water and enjoys himself he also
attends a baseball game and shouts in
excitement that he finally knows what
his father was talking about one day it
starts raining and adam feels the rain
water for the first time in his life he
urges him to return to the house but
adam wants to keep experiencing the
wonderful feeling out of nowhere he hugs
eve tightly implying that he is enjoying
life in the real world and that perhaps
he has finally achieved his first boner
later that evening evened troy take adam
to a 1940s swing style nightclub to find
him a wife they advise him to be himself
while approaching women surprisingly
adam attracts the attention of several
women including eve's nemesis sophie
when he and sophie start to get along
eve feels uncomfortable and drags adam
away to a table she then recommends that
he look for a sweet girl instead of
sophie after a while adam approaches a
girl and they soon get along when he
asks her for a dance in no time adam
woos the crowd with his exemplary
dancing skills as he has had years of
practice inside the bunker oh yeah he
got it from his mama meanwhile a jealous
eve reconnects with her ex-boyfriend who
pokes adam into an argument however he
soon regrets it when adam demonstrates
his boxing skills having trained every
single day with his father in the bunker
because of all the commotion eve gets
irritated and decides to abandon adam
and return home a while later troy also
arrives and informs eve that adam left
the club with sophie hearing this eve
storms out of the house and gets in her
car to go get adam back just as she is
about to drive off adam suddenly knocks
on the door startling the life out of
her following this the two returned to
the house and adam explains that he
politely rejected sophie as he could
only think of eve he then expresses his
love for her and the two finally kiss
now with eve by his side he decides to
tell her about his past he reveals that
he lived in a fallout bunker with his
family for 35 years and is seeing the
outside world for the first time he also
expresses his desire to make eve his
wife and take her to the bunker so that
they can live a happy life however eve
thinks he is crazy and asks him to leave
the following day while learning to
drive a truck with troy adams spots the
adult video store from earlier and
finally discovers his bunker's location
he hurries back to eve's house to tell
her about his finding but he notices two
psychiatrists waiting for him there adam
initially cooperates but escapes after
giving even troy the key to his hotel
room he asks them to take all the cards
and pay his hotel bill before driving
away in a truck a while later troy and
eve reach adam's room in the hotel and
find clothing toothpaste and other items
from the 1960s they also come across
some valuable stock certificates of
adam's father which are now worth
millions with this they conclude that
adam is not crazy and he was actually
telling the truth the whole time in the
meantime adam returns home after two
weeks of staying in the outside world he
hugs his parents and tells them about
how lovely the world has become soon
melker and his friends help adam to load
the supplies into the bunker on the
other hand even troy try to locate
adam's underground bunker but to no
avail at night while they are returning
home eve spots adam outside the adult
video store she immediately calls out
his name and gets out of the car they
embrace and kiss each other and adam
takes her to meet his parents calvin and
helen are impressed with eve but adam
wants his father to wait for two months
while he makes arrangements outside
during this time adam and eve sell the
stocks to build a new home in the
country identical to his previous house
they plan to bring calvin and helen
slowly to the surface and start a new
life with them after a few months adam's
parents arrive at their new home they
are astonished to see their son do so
much for them while helen and eve
prepared dinner for the family adam
reveals to his father that there was
never an atomic war and that the bomb
was not a bomb instead a plane crashed
into their house he also reveals that
the soviet union collapsed without a war
however calvin is unconvinced and makes
fun of his son's revelation the movie
ends as calvin plans to build a new
fallout bunker as eve watches from the
kitchen window and plays with her
engagement ring
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching